A star Spangled sky is a truly amazing and tremendous sight.
These lights twinkling in the night have charmed humans since times a Memorial
and inspired them to dream and strive for new discoveries. However,
there are places in our galaxy where the star count in the sky is several times
higher than that in the earth eye.
These aren't the dim and cool lights we're used to seeing either,
but an exceptionally dazzling multitude of large stars.
It is hard to imagine what it looks like,
but this is what the universe appears to be seen from the center of one of the
largest superstar clusters in our galaxy Westerland. One.
A star cluster is a group of stars,
which formed from one in the same gigantic cloud vintage. Stella matter.
These stars are practically identical in terms of their chemical composition and
age.
The system they form is bound by gravity forces,
star clusters fall into either of these two categories,
which are the main varieties open and globular clusters.
Open star clusters are products of Stellan air series evolution.
The latters are areas of cosmic gas where stars are actively born.
That is why the clusters here are mainly com prized of young stars and great
amounts of vintage Stella hydrogen gravity forces between them are comparatively
feeble,
which leads to an open cluster's disintegration several hundred million years
after its formation, which of course is mere seconds in astronomical terms.
Some of its former members still stick together in their joint, move in space,
thus forming a Stella stream while others break away from their group to become
so masters of their own destiny.
Over 1,100 open star clusters have been pinpointed in our
galaxy and incidentally,
it appears to be just a tiny portion of their overall count.
Global clusters are larger and dense sir,
than open ones and consist of old and not very massive stars.
The average distance between the stars,
there is four to six slight months as for their masses.
These may reach a million times out of the sun.
The Milky way contains not less than 150 star clusters of this type
and the Andro Galax over 500 open clusters are
comparatively modest in size,
but the stock count in some of them reaches thousands.
These objects are referred to as superstar clusters.
The largest of them are thought to eventually turn into lobular ones.
All it will take is waiting around for a few billion years or so until the most
massive stars there have burned out and exploded.
One of the largest superstar clusters in our galaxy is one referred to as
Westerland one.
It was spotted back in 1961 by Swedish astronomer, banked Westerland,
but for a long while,
remained largely understudied as it is quite difficult to observe the
dis from the cluster center to the solar system has been estimated at
approximately 10,000 to 15,000 light years.
Staggering though this figure may seem Westerland won is in fact,
one of our closest superstar clusters.
That is why it is crucial to observe it,
to bring our understanding of stellar evolution processes, to a hone your level,
the diameter of Westerland.
One measures around seven light years astoundingly this area,
which is really tiny in astronomical terms is fully crowned with thousands
of stars with a total mass of about 63,000 solar masses.
Some straightforward calculations share the distances between the major members
of the cluster are just several light months as for binary system components.
They're much closer to each other than that, due to incredible density of the,
in the cluster and the clouds of Interstella gas,
the stars are shrouded in it is impossible to distinguish the exact sources of
night here as the thousands of stars.
This light comes from are too densely packed.
This greatly interferes with observations and doesn't allow the observer to
count the star. That is why the exact star count in Westland.
One remains to be gauged among them.
The following types of stars have already been pinpointed six yellow hyper
giants, four red super giants, 24 Wolfrey stars,
and a super giant with a highly peculiar emission spectrum.
Supposedly it formed on collision of two massive stars. In addition,
the is a great number of hot blue giants and an x-ray Parsa discovered among the
stars and the cluster lap Palsa is an anomalous object and neutron star
spinning with a mind boggling spade.
The binary star count is also quite high in Westland. One.
This fact may be accounted for by the high density of the clusters objects.
All the superstar clusters objects are positive to have formed as round one at
the same time. However, depending on a type of stars,
they differ in terms of their rage too, to start with,
according to today's theory of stellar evolution,
red super giants can be younger than 4 million years. Willette stars.
On the other hand,
which are in the final stage of their life cycle by definition are remarkably
numerous in the cluster.
Their life expectancy known almost never to have been over 5 million years.
Thus the age of Westerland one is quite accurately estimated at a may four to
5 million years,
which in essence is seconds in astronom terms at approximately
the same time it was forming first Olos and Sabretooth
tigers roamed the earth.
And all that had been left of dinosaurs by then was just the fossilized remains
mathematical modeling of the clusters formation shows that the cluster may have
contained 50 to 150 heavy stars that would've depleted their resources
by now.
And so would've come to the final stage of their life cycle.
Given the estimates are correct on average,
there would've been super Nova every 10,000 years in the course of last million
years, as we know the heavier a star,
the fast seed comes to the end of its lifecycle and goes super Nova after which
it leaves a black hole neutron star or wide dwarf. However,
to date only one object like that has been detected.
It is thought that many super massive stars would've turned into black holes,
but these are rather difficult to spot today.
The superstar cluster Westland one contains one of the largest stars known
today.
Designation Westland 1 26,
since it is rather difficult to observe it.
Its radius has been gauged at roughly 1,500 to
2,500 times that of the sun,
if its radius is closer to the bigger margin Westerland,
1 26 may the biggest star known to mankind. However,
the radius is more likely to lie closer to the lower margin and measure slightly
over 1,500 times that of the sun, even.
So if its center were to be theoretically placed in that of the sun,
Westland 1 26 would cover all the planets reaching.
As far as the orbit of Jupiter,
the super giant luminosity is approximately 380,000 times
out of the sun. Although its surface temperature is comparatively low,
just around 3000 Kelvin, the stars mass hasn't been engaged yet,
but today's perception of stellar evolution allows us to assume that it may be
around 20 solar masses.
Another unusual object in the cluster is a Magnetar with a name like a tongue
twister.
It is also the most powerful source of x-ray radiation in that area of space
located approximately 16,000 light years from the sun.
It is a neutron star whose rotation period is about 10 seconds.
Incidentally, this is rather slow in comparison to other objects of this class.
Those rotate several times a second,
given that all the stars in the cluster formed it around one of the same time.
It would've taken the star.
That was the progenitor of this Magnetar just 5 million years to deplete its
Thermo nuclear fuel. This means that when it was born,
its mass should have been not less than 40 solar masses. However, in that case,
it should have left a black hole rather than a neutron star after going
supernova,
it transpires that the proje star had to unaccountably lose up to 95%
of its mass before going super and over.
One of the possible answers to this riddle may lie in the fact that the object
may have originated from a binary star rather than a single one,
by spinning around the common mass center at an astounding rate,
the systems components had a chance of actively exchanging material.
At some point,
the supernova would've scattered most of this material in the space around it.
While the second components would've been ejected from the system,
the star Westerland one five,
which is local comparatively close to the Magnetar may well have been that very
component.
Although it is not certain, unfortunately,
chances of discovering any planets in the superstar cluster Westland,
one are thin. First of all,
the stars the clusters comprised of are too young for any planets to form in
their environments.
This curious process takes hundreds of millions of years at the very least.
Secondly, even billions of years later,
when the cluster supposedly turns into a globular one,
it is hardly worthwhile to anticipate any objects to be born there that would
potentially be capable of sustaining life.
The close proximity of large and heavy stars makes the potential planets orbits
unstable. Moreover in certain circumstances,
a massive neighbor relatively close to a star system may actually destroy it
completely.
Besides thousands of active stars concentrated in a small area of space,
create a remarkably powerful radiation background,
frequent flares of supernova occurring in this crowned space may cause harmful
Gare bursts, which destroy any life on a planet's surface.
Chances are that even if mankind finds a way to cover Interstella distances,
clusters will still remain deadly areas for quite a while,
either way,
all these speculations don't put a damper on the charms and beauty of the starry
heavens the cosmos is a limitless source of knowledge about the universe for
scientists and a source of inspiration for artists for all we know
at some point it may become and you home for mankind.
And while this time hasn't yet come, we will just keep make king.
You informative episodes. Let's keep in touch.